i could tell they were getting addressed  and i thought what does this have to do  with heaven  the f.l the husband short creek always  believed that warren jess was the  prophet  for a man to become a god he must have a  plurality of wives the ones he would  groom were the lambs the ranch was his  personal perverted playboy mansion  warren scribe was one of his wives naomi  jeffs she's taking down records of where  they are every day what warren is saying  as they're traveling she wrote down a  road map to criminal activity we were  really interrupting an entire culture of  sexual abuse he would tell us he was in  a heavenly session with all these ladies  getting undressed i just couldn't  believe it was happening  naomi helped warren stay on the run i am  so grateful to be the way of our holy  prophet  to this day i'd still like to talk to  her  where do you want me to start  you